a recent lawsuit claims some Americans
were lured to Mexico for weight loss
surgeries that turned out to be
dangerous or even life-threatening for
people from Arizona are suing three
doctors in Mexico who performed
surgeries their suit also names
companies in the US which they claim
arranged for the surgeries and referred
the patients to those doctors Anna
Werner went to Mexico for this
investigation Anna good morning good
morning Nora experts say many people can
benefit enormous ly from those weight
loss surgeries improving not only their
weight but overall health
but a gastric sleeve or lap band surgery
can cost as much as twenty thousand
dollars and what if your insurance plan
won't cover it one New Mexico woman told
us her story of a trip south of the
border she now regrets I've been
overweight since I was 16 Diana Thomas
struggled with her weight for decades at
one point reaching 290 pounds my weight
was killing me I needed to do something
about it
her doctor suggested gastric sleeve
surgery a procedure where a surgeon
removed some 80% of the stomach people
eat less and lose weight but it can cost
up to $20,000 in the US and Thomas's
work insurance didn't cover it then she
found an online company weight loss
agents offering to help people get the
procedure in Tijuana for five thousand
dollars with a doctor named Mario
Almanza she says she and her husband did
their research we were comfortable in
the fact with what we knew it's what we
didn't know that would have stopped me
altogether what she didn't know that
some patients who've gone to Mexico have
suffered serious consequences says dr.
Sam Erma Tarr who heads an American
bariatric surgeons group they are
attracted there because of deep
discounts to have these operations over
there unfortunately some of them come
back with complications that we have to
take care of I was dying I felt like I
was dying
six days after surgery back in the US
she wound up in an emergency room where
doctors found she had a hole a leak in
her gastric sleeve and a
life-threatening infection they called
her family to her bedside
were you frightened I was scared to
death and I just hope that they would
make it in time so I could come I love
them and get my last hug Thomas did not
sue dr. Almanza but for Arizona
residents have now filed a class-action
lawsuit against dr. Almanza to other
mexico-based doctors and associated US
companies accusing them of fraud and
saying they concealed the risks and
dangers associated with having bariatric
surgeries done into who ana weight-loss
agents is not named in the lawsuit we
wanted to know what dr. Almanza had to
say he agreed to speak with us so we're
headed to Tijuana we met him at his new
facility this nondescript white building
this is where you do the surgery my
feeling wrong inside he showed us around
how many surgeries in a day he says he
does between five and ten surgeries a
day and we met patients like Arizona's
Doug Taylor and his wife joy they both
had the surgery after doctors in the
u.s. told joy she wasn't heavy enough to
qualify and what did you think of that I
thought why can't I have it done they
paid roughly thirty six hundred dollars
a piece we found out about this place
and we just said that's gold for it
dr. Almanza told us he's a credentialed
surgeon with a complication rate of less
than 2% my walk is is professional were
the surgeries done correctly yeah Paula
still here
images all of the surgeries are done
well before this he told us we have
processes and we don't jump steps and
what of the lawsuit he claims a former
employee tried to blackmail him then
offered some of his former patients $500
a piece to complain about him there was
a campaign in opposition of me to take
away my prestige he told us but we also
found two families who say their loved
ones died after surgeries by dr. Almanza
there
deaths also referenced in that lawsuit
it could have been made up by the
patient's doctor Almanza told us he says
he hasn't seen death certificates to
prove they died from his surgeries and
what about Diana Thomas he claims she
too was bribed Thomas says it's
ridiculous five hundred dollars she says
wouldn't have made a dent in her three
hundred thousand dollars in medical
bills bills that forced her to declare
bankruptcy my whole purpose for this is
to bring awareness to what can happen I
want him stopped cuz it's not just me
now weight loss agents says it has no
legal ties to dr. almanza's medical
practice but helps with scheduling
transportation and other services
it says safe treatment is it's paramount
goal and it warns customers of possible
risks another doctor named in the
lawsuit told us having surgery in Mexico
is a good thing because some people are
desperate and can't afford it here in
the u.s. sounds like one of those
stories so you get what you pay for it
people always say if it's not and your
mom would say that if it sounds too good
to be true it probably is
but I'm surprised that he talked to you
Anna knowing what you were going to be
talking to him about the doctor he
actually was was willing to talk to us
about all the allegations against Jimmy
answered them the way you heard he has
meant maintained for a while now that
there was this blackmail scheme but for
instance Diana Thomas says the $500
bribe allegation is ludicrous you know
she went bankrupt because of her bills
because the insurance companies won't
pay and he seems to have had some
success too but it's still there a dicey
situation the the lesson is research
recess research remember that diana
thomas is ok yeah better